I shoot so many you know I only use
about one out of six one out of five or
six that issue yeah so there's all day
all [ __ ] things that sometimes I don't
use anything Oh
when crazy crazy crazy oh my god
things in my life you know anyhow
that's all you need just a little bit
like that oh cool
what does crack do for you what does it
do for me most of the time I well now
that I'm older
actually this whole last little run god
I've been swimming a lot though for like
steady since uh 2013 you know 2020
oh my god but um I got a prison whose
last time I got out that was after you
know I I got out my when I went in it
was 2013 in May and I was told my mom
passed away and then the very next week
I was the seven-year 22 spinet sentence
was imposed because I didn't have a
piece of paper saying I completed the
program although I did it's how you say
I'm over over the mountain case it was a
90-day program I did 114 days you know
but I didn't have that paper hmm which
was like crazy but um anyhow so the
following we thought that was imposed
and then the next week I was in prison
morning my mom you know and I didn't
know that she had dementia you know and
I didn't find out until I was on a are
you know the receiving or that's
everything in your artichoke shilla and
um when it was explained to me
uh I think with my head phone worms you
know but um I always got my headphones
yeah all the time
gotta have my music got to you so so so
Doreen where'd you grow up were you from
from the valley San Fernando Valley
there's only one Valley
okay only one and I hate when people say
what Valley there's only one yeah it's
like oh my god they totally hear
whatever like huh where's your childhood
like um I was very quiet I was very
quiet quiet I didn't talk about it at
all
very quiet I remember even when I first
was on Columbus Street you know which is
off of Sepulveda
that was a infamous drive-thru you know
crack get you're a rock you know I mean
back in see his sight back on
88 88 87 is when I first started
swimming crack it was actually not crack
then it was cocaine got her and that was
in Northridge you know you know real
rock house the tree blooming at you and
to really rock out you know everybody's
just smoking yeah yet mom and dad was a
kid um no my my father passed away when
I was five and a half weeks old he named
me Doreen which means gift it derives to
the Greek word door which means gift and
my mom had no choice in it you know my
name I'm Greek you know my great
grandparents when my father say father's
side came from Greece from Sparta and
someplace call him a lot of I can't even
begin to figure that pronunciation you
know what was southern Greece how was
your childhood how was it there it was
some I was safe secure my mom was a
heroin addict I remember when I was 2
she put me and my older sister in a
foster in foster care a real nice house
I remember that very well
the lady gruesome vintage on the side of
the house and I love vegetables
I mean pacified meat with vegetables
forget a sucker for good ice cream soda
all that stuff bolstering means my mom
did that one bullet ring me I was like
I'm not gonna stop crying I just
remember saying that you know night
that's how I was then eating that whole
bull I wasn't crying them we're so so
you started using drugs at what age 17
and a half oh it was late August of 1987
I told my mom I wanted to try it
she's like oh hey you know I mean I
tried it and I was like ten second nine
I was like forget that you know you know
rather get high and acid be high for
like 15 hours you mean you know cuz I'd
try to ass it at that time to like five
hits like total you know you know I
don't know they didn't really appeal to
me you know
I mean really really get into it until I
went to this house it was like sitting
around the kitchen table it was like
huge kitchen table all night and just
smoking and before I got left out the
front door um I mean we were just puking
that's how much I smoked you know I
threw up you know and pretty much from
there on I was smoking every day
mm-hmm since 17 and a half
yeah because me sheeni july/august
actually I was barely 17
no where's that taking your life prison
a lot of time I've done a lot of time
prostituting to support my habit I
actually made a decision to prostitute
instead of rob people or rob places you
know II mean I'll sell drugs you know
how is that how is that decision
affected you um does it change the way
you do man is it make your life more
dangerous is it
I don't know it's it's a prettier way I
was it's like a good in a bag yeah
what are the goods of that the the good
is that I got to be able to experiment
more because I was always seeking you
know the sensation you know a feeling
you know sexually I was molested when
when I was 13 it was my mom's boyfriend
and he just asked to go down on me and
he told me I could say no you know and
made me feel very comfortable
I'm very comfortable and I'm one day I'm
I'm the most sensitive girl out of my
mom's three daughters you know I mean we
haven't celebrated or acknowledged every
holiday every single one you know and
for me to feel so comfortable even now
to this day you know I'm it was like a
light switch you know I mean like you
you don't even think about it when it's
off its off you just walk away you never
have another lingering attached thought
to it you know and I have full control
you know what I mean I have full control
and I'm the one that actually initiated
the intercourse part you know and it
never hurt it took him many times before
I actually went all the way in
got all the way and I said stop he
stopped literally just stopped right
there as soon as I said stop you know I
even hid from my own mother
you know when she'd come home you know I
mean it was scrambling the enemy to get
dressed and stuff I know that
your whole I was 13 and it went on until
I was 17 times 17 that guy huh
that man just really drastically
affected every single woman in that in
that home you know because my mom had
got at home the first mortgage was paid
by Cecil you know that was the contract
that my mother made with him for
starting the business that in getting
the Corvette but she didn't end up
getting a Corvette she got in another
car
we got a brand-new house up in acting it
was really nice ass house but my mom
didn't like because it was a mouse mice
up there so we went back to the house on
Long Ridge 63 27 long Avenue and so
that's basically where I grew up
even though my mom started using heroin
again when she got with this man she
always provided safe secure place and I
mean clean and always food you know what
I mean there was never I never seen my
mom slam ever you know I knew what she
did you know I had no worries in that
area
you know but everything that she tried
to like sequester you know me from was
in that family you know I mean drugs be
molested you know all that violence you
know everything you know it was pretty
much there you know I don't know but I
don't know in a way I guess you know I I
had a good childhood I had a good
childhood even though you know even so I
had to get childhood I knew my mommy
loved me I no doubt of that
I was for sure never had a doubt she
didn't even have to say it she I grew up
as the middle child but an only child
because she sent both my sister's
somewhere else to live once she started
using again because she had a
hysterectomy that's what she said it's
triggered her to use again but it was it
is because she was with that guy you
know and he was using you know and so
eventually it's gonna effect
but anyhow so when I started using I got
arrested my first time I got arrested
this on Rosco and Sepulveda and they got
me for under the influence personally a
possession spitting out a cop and false
information I spit out the cop cuz I was
underage you know I mean I have one of
those cutouts shirts you know that the
muscle shirts and having a bra and it
kept falling off because I was
handcuffed and you know it's trying to
ask me you know to put it up to where
they want to keep falling you know and
they win it and they were making lewd
conduct you know comments you know the
police officers as they were going by in
the station so I spit out warned the
cops I was like you know you know so
that's the charge I had gotten you know
and then pretty much from there I never
knew god I wish I'd never tried smoking
cocaine ever because once you know you
know you can never go back from he can
never go back to not knowing you know
you can't you can't once you know you
know you know
so today you're living on Skid Row
yeah cuz I ran away from the valley I
ran away from the Sepulveda Sapulpa it
used to drive me crazy literally I've
gotten all my time there
it's a it was drugs and prostitution and
yeah just the rough life yeah then
coming down here okay I get what do you
gain by coming down Skid Row
uh well I got four all got a probation
um I made a lot of great people I mean
the people out here are extraordinary
every single one of them are
extraordinary the women out here a good
I would say 80% of the women right here
in this this area especially on the
bottom side I've known for many years
decades because we've done time
throughout the years you know and so
I've always known them without getting
high and they've always known me as
quiet playing bridge you know to me and
I've been like really like way out out
here you know but uh it's been an
experience
never thought I would have been
boisterous very boisterous a very loud
voice chourus there was a point where
actually I couldn't even stop myself I'm
talking that had had to do with my mom's
my mom going to dementia you know she
really affected me psychologically
affected me you know because she she
wouldn't let me get like one sentence he
barely even half a sentence completed
you know and like I said I didn't have
no idea what she was this she had to
mention what it does I had no idea until
after she passed away you know and I
actually chose to come here specifically
specifically right here in Skid Row two
more my mother you know with people that
at least in my face you know and then
they've gotten to know me and care about
me they really do care they really truly
care a lot you know damn they've gotten
to know know me and just by observing me
just by observing me you know
got a lot of love and care out here
which is so crazy because the one the
man that I love a lot oh my god I would
what I've been through with him
there's just extreme extreme never in my
life have I have I doing so much
monetarily wise yeah just so much but I
you know I've been hard on him too you
know in ways you know I can't really
tell him exactly you know but pretty
much just like each other for the ring
is still kind of doing it but um I don't
know I'm still there you know I don't
know he's I don't know he's ready to
give up you know to me and go I don't
know what I'd do without him you know
won't be the same
you know I won't feel safe either I felt
very ok before he came into my life you
know I have no worries you know and I
knew who was who you know what's what
and either you know associated with who
not to associate with but I talked to
everybody no matter what you know no
matter what you know I've got a rapport
with it was just about everybody here as
far as the men are concerned on a
one-on-one we have an individual report
you know and because of that that is
kept me safe
you know from harm the women too they
just know who I am and I mean they don't
trip on me at all you know how do you
think all these years of living this
lifestyle has changed you can you
imagine a different doreen if you hadn't
taken to drugs and prostitution and this
whole street life thing you know
downtown ease is skill road and being
down here is what's really changed me a
lot being down here my experiences down
here has really changed me a lot
you know from from leaving the sober
living home yeah
I was really okay you know I was really
okay
I felt pretty you know I mean I was self
okay you know I need outside things you
know I really didn't you know I had
everything I needed as far as monetarily
wasn't that just enough back pay to be
able to put that down payment on
apartment you don't mean it's moving
costs you know just enough it was like
1,500 you know it was just barely enough
you know and why I use my period see
I've had like this holding all through
my life right and when I got Melissa you
know I know that something like shut
down in my head but I didn't really
realize until just recently really how
much it affected me I mean it's really
affects me really hard you know and for
me to reach an obtain with it you know
that that feeling to be [ __ ] by Matt
you don't mean just like it's a woman
you know I mean that that whole feeling
in not just coming but having an orgasm
which is completely different like I've
had an orgasm but it was like even my
baby's father head you know he's like
you gotta come back down to earth you
gotta come back down cuz you're like you
know that's the only way I can explain
it but I want to feel that sensation
having intercourse
you mean and the man that I'm with now
he's been able to attain you a certain
state of it but you know she that's why
I was like a I've always been able to
experiment and you know you know seek
you only and just like you know test
this and that you know and because of it
you know the choice I'd meets a
prostitute you know I've had much
experience you know had different men
you know and different things and
different situations
one thing I've come to learn is that my
chemistry my chemistry my that one
hormone that gets this release when a
woman goes on a period just like the
second or third day is more it's at the
highest highest release I learned that
when I was at a MIDI I finally got to
the point where
at that time I was like [ __ ] it why
start if it I'm just gonna get just
winning you know he's gonna be the same
thing you know so I'm not gonna begin
you know I get you know because I've
been through a you know I mean many
experiences where I've had guys that
really wanted to you know I mean take
that time and everything you know really
cool and I got along with them and there
was like something there you know II
mean and cuz it's got to be something
there that's another that's first and
foremost when the other guy gotta have
some type of feeling towards a man some
kind of something he's got to be there
for me to feel and then it was a
chemistry thing you know that in there
next and then the third thing the
biggest thing was um if I choose I chose
to be with a guy Oscar
it wasn't cuz there anything that he
said that he could do or or anything
like that it didn't have anything to do
with him or what he wanted or might want
or whatever you know which man that just
like opened a whole door like completely
different were like I felt every touch
when he touched me you said I felt each
touch fully you know it wasn't really
the sensation that you know as far as
you know you know vaginally but um
detectives I felt and I realized you
know there's choice choosing really
choosing you know not having control but
she's gonna be with somebody because I
want to
not because they want to a mind like to
whatever you know and so that was cool
you know and then you know there there's
with me you gotta be able to reach each
part of me here you gotta be if you
don't care you got to care about me
there's got to be some kind of care and
love you got to reach my soul you know
pretty much got to otherwise I won't
I won't you know did I get a move now
Gary you know I don't even like anybody
touching my titties because they're so
sensitive you know and I like him to
touch him
I like them to go down on me I don't
like that you know to me because I dream
less of it and please I don't really get
anything from it you know she's a hard
case huh there's a little girl still you
know she's trying to grow up babe you
know she be like sitting down you know
on me you know and she's like no no no
no I'm not good okay yeah like a little
girl you know it even I have our time
you know like just last uh last night I
was like oh good go ahead and do it in
the shower cuz I can get myself off you
know I've learned different ways where I
can in different sensations but really
to get the release you know like coming
you know that kind of release is in the
shower with water you know and I just
figured that one out because I heard the
girls over you know it being locked up
talking about the water you know okay
well I tried it once and it worked you
know to me and and so it's changed over
the years but now it's like it's so hard
to get it you know sometimes because
it's like one very specific spot you
know and I don't know if that's just
because how I'm made down there or what
you know I don't know you know there was
one time once I was in the motel it uh
you know I was with this guy named
Walter he looks like just so he's like
the Rollie pollie ties up with glasses
he smoked crack I mean but he's like
I've met many men but he's the only man
that I've really met man you know
because he couldn't envision me going
out to go sell my body to provide a roof
over my head after much how it was that
when he realized I was gonna go to oh no
he wouldn't let me you know enemy and
therefore he went and put his life in
jeopardy
he was a Robin ralph's you know and he
was really giving good you know and he
provided more than I could um ever
provide for myself you know and uh there
was this one time wait this was one time
and it was like three weeks before we
even did anything specially and we
didn't really do all the way it was like
we were like little kids too at the same
time it was very intimate very intimate
and open
he didn't even indicate by an eyelash
one of his eyelashes said he was
interested in me and I would be walking
around butt naked you know which you
know many can't really handle that you
know for me you know I've learned you
know I've learned what if about myself
as far as my beauty in another way down
here in skid row from the men you know
even the women you know have you know
confided in me in certain ways you know
and told me certain things you know
Walter the one that says is the only man
that I have ever really met he said it's
not because I asked him what is it about
me you know me I'd be like what is it
you know he said he's like everybody
wants Dede that's my nickname in the
valley everybody wants Dede
I'm like what do you mean everyone see
he said even the girls want did he like
no he's like why he was me you couldn't
understand it he could not understand
you know it is not about I don't go out
to fizzle your physique doesn't matter
to me money doesn't matter to me you
can't give me that way you know you
can't even give me that with crack you
know if I choose because I choose to
I really have to choose to you know what
I mean and the guys learned that about
me down here you know that that's
something different about me you know I
do have certain morals and ethics no
matter what crack don't change that you
know cuz I mean you know I'm Who I am
and will always be hello I think that's
Amanda okay she's just so exciting down
here i I want to write a book okay okay
okay
yeah
which one is that
Amanda Amanda the young girl she walks
around like shoeless she's schizophrenic
so she had a slightly serious problems
and they she's doing crack cocaine like
a fiend so yeah that combination is bad
I love these girls down here I've
admired the women down here you don't
have to love it when I you know thought
about it I realized you know these women
they've been through some really scary
stuff because it used to be completely
different down here I you see you're the
stories down here you know from them you
know and it was really treacherous and
hard on these women and they still stand
tall and he still are who they are
there's in or out cuz I know them sober
mostly yeah I know them without doing
drugs mostly and they're the same
individuals you know and they've been
through hell they don't never talk about
it except when they come in this little
road yeah but generally these people
just are resisting with all this damage
and all this terrible I have such
admiration I look of teeth for me I look
at each and every single one of them the
ones that people look down I still look
up to them you know and and I wish I
could so much you know be able to have
that kind of strength endurance self
self-recognition you know I mean that
men and what they may do or environment
what may happen has not destroyed that
and you know and you know we're truly
are God's people down here God in
heavens people right here really
cherished by him and I know this all
right thank you very much for sharing
your story it's great to be here though
it really is great to be here even on
the worst days it's part of life
humanity part you know but you're like
yeah god bless god bless everybody and I
love everybody I really do thank you I
was stumbling a little bit that's me
yeah that's circulation in my mouth
no no Jesus everyone has a different
style of communicating he's buried in
same words
you